But who's to say that you always have to work alone? What if you guys solved
the problems together? The amount of work you do in 1 hour plus the amount of
work Anthony does in 1 hour, would equal the total fraction of work you both
can do in 1 hour. In other words, we knew that you could complete half of the
job in 1 hour. And Anthony can complete a third of the job in 1 hour. So if we
add these 2 fractions together, this would be the total sum of the fraction of
the job that you both could do in 1 hour's time. Notice that the denominator
here represents the time that it took for you do the entire job. And for
Anthony, the 3 represents the amount of time it took for him to do the entire
job. This means that x represents the total number of hours for you and Anthony
to do that job together. So working together, how long would it actually take
you and Anthony to complete the assignment together? Write the number of hours
it would take them to complete the work together here. And then convert that
answer to the number of minutes it would take them to complete the work here.
Keep in mind I don't want you to write your answer as hours and minutes. I want
you to write the fraction or the number of hours here and then convert that
fraction to the toal number of minutes here.